welcome this video playing x what kind
of flag is that tatarstan ok very
difficult to even make out what's what's
on there see having something loose
tongue juice Newton off Wow grant massa
yeah yeah many gems can playing the
field chatter variation for a change ok
so we get a transposition to a sort of
symmetrical English I normally play with
night see to air let's do that y term
typically has good control IAM over t5
long term i can get in like v3 Bishop b2
93 Queen d2 and just sort of control
things
right it took took ages for that move
looks very normal okay um what is he
doing let's say but should be six I
probably just go be three I cannot do
much on the long diagonal I ok I think
this is also known line queen age five I
go eform we might trade queens yeah I
think this is this is a known line maybe
with luck bishop should be six be three
inserted but this has been played before
I definitely you can also play Bishop g4
now Bishop g4 f3 ok Knight g4
interesting so what about what is he
doing after h3 really Knight f6 back all
he does not mind this this crappy pawn
structure no he doesn't mind the support
structure interesting ok so is there
like Bishop aged three years could be a
technical issue here like Bishop takes
Bishop takes Knight f3 check night XD to
uh huh this might be an idea
yeah a little bit late that I'm seeing
that but at the end um why is the night
going I don't know Bishop takes Bishop
takes Knight a three checking g2 yeah
yeah those little tactics they are as I
see all the time Bishop takes Knight f3
kingi 292 look the one I can take on c3
and take you for that that's really bad
okay so I'm going to just play with this
without the pawn but whatever his extra
point is on age 51 h7s is nothing really
great of course i have just blundered
this but whatever I mean I saw the idea
but I couldn't really figure out what to
do against it
okay he's got them possibly something
coming to deform I want I want to try
Knight to f4 I'm still not sure how bad
my position really is i mean this pond
is not does not look so important I dis
hard for him to keep him and always even
giving it away right away should I take
it down i guess i should know i can take
plane i def where this is excellent for
white again not again I was never
excellent before but does this is okay
Bishop age 3 maybe an idea form in my
yes some checks but ultimately but
ultimately it should should be a problem
for him this Bishop only 6 and this
bishop the bishop is pointing towards e6
what I'm was trying to say okay going
for the passive cabin I see ya he's got
Knight f3 maybe I should just cover dad
make sure that everything is protected
check
p iu wants to get in here but I can take
I can now can this check is annoying
definitely it definitely is
I still can take it's not like it's
losing check takes takes Bishop takes hy
still have a move like I have don't have
bishop you one but it's not it's not the
problem anyway I can also do that he has
some given me be five so
yep my time my time time warning yeah
yeah I know
check is got night have to ha silly very
silly yeah that's basically the only way
to lose this fall for one of his one
move tricks panic strategically this was
a very weird game by black ok 995 I'm
falling apart nom ah what a bad loss
that was really bad
yeah the problem is that i'm absolutely
down on time the position of course now
is to question but I've got one and one
punt one pawn down right yeah and I find
the score so I'm also lost on the on the
board yeah thats it's a bit of annoying
game I had a very had a very nice
position really I can take it from okay
it's like there's I yeah I sort of lost
a bit of control your hip like it's hip
like it's just outplayed I think oh I'm
surprised the computer is only giving
why the slight edge which is strange I
just have two bishops in an open
position and that's it's just the wrong
assessment by the comp I know it gets
higher okay Adam gathered I mean this is
the cs is just excellent for white
definitely here here i need to play here
need to improve I just if I just play
play well now how do you how do you do
that 95 of course yeah right there for
ya maybe not i just just do this this is
just much much better of course yeah
getting the i was sort of afraid of this
check on g3 but this is nonsense i can
just check as something not helping you
know now g6 now e6 is hanging and he has
no good moves to do that to defend that
this is losing directly going back is
very sad yeah we can just slowly slowly
improve and throop g6 is what the
combustor gesture suggesting but check
Jim plus 1.5 I've got 96 coming and
black is just busted yeah it needed to
be I mean this versus couldn't be any
good this is kind of this kind of
position you play to play the very weird
very weird here from i was i was losing
this oops I'm sorry i was losing this
this pawn due to the tech tech but right
here i don't have a way to stop that
it's very very weird okay that this is
probably the relatively best thing it's
it's not it's not so terrible for wide
really um I have a decent position still
around here I'm getting getting a good
plan I'm surprised really that if black
its computer wants to do a move like
that and just says 0.2 this time this
seems very very outlandish why shouldn't
white have an advantage here I have more
space i have two bishops he's got a
weakness only six why is this just 0.3
looks like like garbage to me for black
I mean it's not like directly losing but
he's clearly a clearly worse we had when
he really weird just 0.3 yeah ultimately
I'm he managed to irritate me enough to
let a blunder stuff okay thanks for
watching